all right some very interesting comments
and ideas from our audience through the
David Pakman show subreddit you can find
the subreddit at david pakman.com slash
re d di t now boasting more than 14,000
david pakman show viewers one of the
largest independent media subreddits out
there and there's an interesting
question here from a user called Aeon
hourglass which is David can you ask
YouTube to make your channel
authoritative and they make a good point
which is we've been talking about how
YouTube has been using this coded
language we are going to prioritize
authoritative news content at the
expense of non-authoritative news
content and I've explained many times we
are caught up in this as non
authoritative and thus we are suffering
the consequences that a lot of the
conspiracy channels and others are
suffering so this is a great idea if the
david pakman show YouTube channel could
be marked as an authoritative news
source by YouTube it would be hugely
beneficial however as the first person
who responded to this said authoritative
is not actually about Authority it's
code for corporate media and that's why
I think it is a great idea I would love
for our channel to be designated
authoritative for our own benefit but
it's code for corporate media to the
greatest extent that I can tell and thus
I don't know that that's something we
can convince YouTube to do also earlier
this week I recommended some books it's
funny the book segments when I recommend
books I've read there never are that
many views for those videos or topics or
clips from the podcast but a lot of
people will email me and say David thank
you so much for the book recommendations
not enough is discussed just about
reading in general everybody's stuck in
social media and smartphones and
whatever thank you for doing it I bought
this book I bought that book a user
called ferret ninja 91 posted a picture
of one of my recommendations in his hand
delta-v by daniel suarez which i read as
i mentioned during my recent vacation in
like five days i couldn't put it down so
i will keep doing it i think i'll do
book recommendations every two weeks i
have such a back cattle
of books I've never talked about that I
can recommend to you and I'm reading so
much these days that there is going to
be no shortage of material and remember
that you can go to david pakman.com
slash recommendations for a list of my
book recommendations both fiction and
nonfiction and please if you use the
links on that page to buy these books
you helped to support the David Pakman
show as well that is all at david
pakman.com slash recommendations and
join the discussion on the subreddit as
well